after 36 hours of standstill finally
take off this morning Gatwick Airport
announced its runway is open and they're
expecting 700 departures today but still
a hundred and twenty-six thousand
passengers are expected to face
disruption today and all night
terminals have been used as a camp site
for many who've been left stranded just
like this family of nine they're meant
to be in Lanzarote by now instead they
spent a night under an escalator we've
had to set up on the stairs to the
departures area because they're on each
other's there are so many people here
that there are no chairs to lay the
children on they're amongst more than
120,000 passengers who have had their
Christmas flights canceled although it's
not been confirmed this may be the
device that the police and army are
looking for for now though the military
search continues as the whereabouts of
the drones and their pilots remains a
mystery and we've got measures in place
now where if the drone appears in terms
of physical response in terms of a
technical response we should be in a
much better position now to track and
capture the dry infective ly though what
you're saying is
we're no further forward at this stage
but we are further forward I mean we
have got our best people on this in
terms of Investigation and like I say
we've got a number of lines of inquiry
and as they come to fruition we'll also
be able to tell you all the transport
Secretary says that all measures
possible will be taken to prevent this
happening again
and this is something that's not being
experienced anywhere in the world with
no one anywhere in the world has
experienced an incident like this before
I hope that nobody else does but we have
got to move very quickly this is it's
not a terror instant in the conventional
sense but it is a disruption incident of
a kind that we have not experienced in
this country before other countries
haven't experienced and we're now going
to make sure we've got all the measures
in place that we possibly can to prevent
this from happening there's still a
number of delays and plenty of catching
up to do
for Gatwick officials the past few days
have been a customer service nightmare
the last 36 hours are demonstrated is
that this is a UK if not international
issue that them is gonna need an awful
lot of work and we'll be taking a lot of
learning across every airport from
what's happened at Gatwick over the last
36 hours we need to continue to work
with industry we've been working with
industry for the last 12 months but as I
stand here today there isn't a
commercial solution that's licensed for
airports that is proven to work it was
fitting that at 6:30 this morning the
first flight eventually left Gatwick
Airport bound for Lapland and a visit to
Santa
but inside passengers remained stranded
and any sighting of a drone means all
operations will be grounded once again
in German rasheed Sky News